le sommeil comme je disais donc minuit
cinq heures c'est déjà une bonne nuit
quand les bébés ses voeux au monde le
réveil peut être brutal pour les parents
car entre la théorie et la pratique ils
sont souvent démunis et se retrouve seul
beaucoup ressentent le besoin de parler
mais ne savent pas vers qui se tourner
ce cercle de parents est fait pour ça la
parole se libère plus facilement de quoi
aider les parents de margaux au sommeil
perturbé
on a un problème est qu'il arrive kalou
est en fait le fait d'en parler
ça rime pas de personnes qu'ils ont
rencontré les mêmes difficultés et que
justement elles ont trouvé de solution
trouvée
seulement 15% des parents font appel aux
services d aide alors que les coups de
blues sont de plus en plus nombreux ces
réunions permettent de faire taire les
questionnements en petit comité à raison
de trois séances gratuites de deux
heures c'est comme ça qu'on apprend à
manger donc ont dévissé les mains et
après ça va être les objets qui vont
être
les habituels alimentation
l'alimentation le sommeil l'allaitement
sont au coeur des angoisses et julie
l'infirmière puéricultrice se fait la
plus discrète possible et non pas
intervenir la plupart du temps parce que
ils ont de meilleur conseil que moi ils
le vivent déjà au quotidien ils
permettent de céder entre
pouvoir dire ce qu'ils peuvent pas dire
des amis à la famille de peur d'être
jugé donc ouvrir
ouvrir la parole délier les langues en
fait si de papa était présent
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt rare une séance
leur sera exclusivement consacrée le 19
février prochain